but ladies and gentlemen we've got a
crazy story if we check this out
alaska airlines flight makes an
emergency landing in seattle after
passenger threatens to kill
everybody on this plane unless you
accept jesus was a black man
now why would he be saying that right
now of all times
you know sean king not just sean king
though it's it's the it's the insanity
of the news cycle that's true
black lives matter is painted everywhere
this zealotry this fanaticism
is it's it's over the top it's
absolutely over the top i mean no one's
out arguing that jesus was a white dude
he was
some people middle eastern it's like i
think for the most part people accept he
was
he was a jew from you know israel or
whatever yeah that's
nazareth everyone who agrees on that
like where are they who are they
yelling at well they were like fighting
with but there are people who
you know like i watched a video on this
jesus was depicted by
every different race as their race yeah
and that's like in the japanese
should that you worship whoever it is
make it who you want it to be like i
don't understand what's wrong well each
culture thinks it represents them
yeah you know what i mean it doesn't
even it doesn't matter to me like
look jesus was a jew from nazareth right
he was jewish he was from nazareth
i don't think i don't i don't if you you
can believe whatever you want to believe
man some people believe
agreement like some people believe some
really crazy stuff yes they do
like white privilege yes i'm kidding
it's a joke well whatever everyone can
believe
whatever they want to believe right
right they think jesus was black that's
okay
but to go on a plane and force it upon
someone else threaten people so check
this out check this out this is
bound for o'hare man of all places they
say in alaska uh video footage from the
incident shows the man wearing a face
mask
moving through the cabin of flight 422
bound for chicago yelling i will kill
everybody in this plane
unless you accept jesus was a black man
as he moves past alarmed passengers in
the seats
he has heard shouting accept it and die
in the name of jesus multiple times
that's right look at this guy this guy's
nuts and he looks like a white dude
according to alaska airlines the flight
took off around 11 15 pm
from seattle tacoma airport and the
incident kicked off 20 minutes in
gee seattle huh what is how about that
you want to hear something crazy bro i
was talking about this story
in portland they let off 59 people on on
charges for protesting yeah nine of them
were for felony riding charges including
arson
and their charges were dropped what
charges dropped
you got something going on crazy in the
pacific northwest but
the craziest part is what in the story
they talk about how
often these the police will arrest these
extremists
and the the grand juries refuse to
indict why
grand juries are not innocent until
proven guilty
grand juries are preponderance of
evidence meaning a grand jury is just
the court says look at this guy bragging
about throwing a molotov cocktail
here's him standing next to a fire that
should be enough for a grand jury to be
like okay put him to trial
and then you get a jury to determine
innocent you know
you know you know to determine probable
cause or whatever right
they couldn't even get that far so this
person was was found standing next to a
burning building like
inside it that's where they arrested
yeah agreed
they posted online apparently to friends
they did it
wow and then admitted to it when it came
to the the grand jury they said no
it wasn't me and the grand jury was like
let them go
like well they said it's not them so
we're just gonna have to trust them on
this one did you see that
nice grand jury you see they called it
uh the fed's an occupying army who
called them that the democrats
tom white senator tom wyden where where
are they occupying
over on the northwest their own federal
courthouse let's let's let's talk about
this next let's finish
let's talk about the story we'll get to
this one next but it's everything trump
supporters said was going to happen
yeah that they were waiting for trump to
make a move we'll we'll come to this one
we'll see we'll say that well let's
let's finish this
i don't want i don't want to derail on
this airline story so apparently it took
three people
to subdue this guy they say the man
became extremely belligerent and
physically aggressive during the the
ascent
an alaska airlines spokesman said three
passengers including a law enforcement
officer and a flight attendant
helped to subdue the man in the clip
obtained by nbc king 5 station
the men are seen following the suspect
down the aisle while everyone else is
buckled in during the ascent
one man then shoves the suspect and is
joined by a second gentleman who helps
to subdue him
video filmed by a passenger shows the
pair take him down as a flight attendant
rushes over with what appears to be zip
ties
to restrain his wrists a worried woman
moves out of her seat before the flight
attendant climbs over the chair to get
to the suspect
that's crazy dude look at this dude
crazy a man
detaining the suspect is heard yelling
at him to stay on the ground and one is
seen reassuring passengers that
everything will be okay
cabin crew then announced the flight
will be landing at the nearest airport
the plane was forced to return to its
origin
following the emergency landing the man
was taken off board by port of seattle
police
he was reportedly cooperative and booked
into king county jail
he was not immediately charged the crime
but was being investigated on suspicion
of harassment
are you nuts terroristic threats he was
threatening
to kill everyone on the plane what dude
i'm not
yeah they're gonna let this guy go and
they're gonna pull some some bs like
well in this case you know we don't
think he really meant
kill he was talking about saving them
they say he was unarmed unharmed during
the attainment and no passengers
reported to be physically harmed
the flight was canceled and the
remaining passengers were booked on
another flight to chicago illinois
this is crazy man well you know what i
bring you now to this story
from snopes i'm very happy that i get to
use snopes for this fact check
did activist sean king say white jesus
statues should come down
king's tweet came as statues of
historical figures were being toppled or
removed in 2020
correct correct attribution thank you
snopes wow they actually
and then they showed it here's what he
said yes i think the statues of white
european
of the white european they claim is
jesus should also come down they are a
form of white supremacy always have been
in the bible when the family of jesus
wanted to hide and blend in guess where
they went
egypt not denmark tear them down he said
look at this yes all murals and stained
glass windows of white jesus and his
european mother
and their white friends should also come
down they are a gross form of white
supremacy created
as tools of oppression racist propaganda
they should all come down
i knew it i i knew they were going to go
after mary i said that when they burned
first
they burned a statue of mary a couple
right they burned one and they and they
tagged another
this is over the top man this is an
attack on the core
of like many people's beings yeah that's
true it's like you
i mentioned this earlier you know you
could uh tear down
a statue of someone you you you idealize
like
you you look up to a founding father
maybe the virgin mary is something well
way different that's like someone
reaching into your heart and squeezing
like there's an attack on
your faith you know your world your life
it's way more serious as far as
you know based on my perspective i
haven't been involved in any of the you
know religious stuff since i was a
little kid
same but it's very very different man
you can get a political argument but
religious stuff is
that's crazy freedom of religion you
want to know what comes next in my
opinion
maybe not next maybe not next but i'll
tell you this man
we were we were briefly watching the
beginning of the new fahrenheit 451
okay it's really well done with michael
b jordan and michael shannon
his name is we were watching the
beginning of it and it's a really
well-written scene
where michael shannon is showing michael
b jordan all these books they found
explaining why they have to destroy them
he's like do you know what's inside
these books
insanity he's like one he's like oh
philosophy or the first thing he brings
up he's like people trying to give their
lives meaning
read read about people who don't even
exist these stories
and he's like oh in philosophy some tell
you that you have free will
they say everything's predetermined it's
nonsense but then he says
he starts getting into offense offense
culture you write a story that's
offensive and the feminists are now
getting all angry
saying how could you write this then
they want those books burned so they do
and he goes ah huckleberry finn
and then he says see they knew this was
offensive to you to the black man so
they have to destroy this book
then he finds another book and he says
see this one was offensive to white
people say to destroy this book
he basically talks about how the
different knowledge
made people angry at each other and by
destroying it all yeah they were able to
unify right
that made me think you know what's going
to happen at some point if we stay on
this track
they will destroy every copy of the
constitution
they will burn it and they'll cheer as
they do
and then when you when they find you
still holding it and believing it
they'll say that was a document made by
white supremacist slave owners
who created it to protect themselves and
their slaveocracy
and yet and you're a white supremacist
for defending it and yet frederick
douglass
used those exact words that's why they
told him in that constitution
to prove that all men are created equal
and they tore his statue down and we
don't we don't know who tore it down
it doesn't matter it was torn down why
was it torn down i think it was torn
down by the far left
i think that's the point yeah man yeah
and it's because
one day there will be a mother and a
child of any race
and they'll be walking past the park and
the child will say
who's that and she'll say that's
frederick douglass he challenged
americans
to uphold their own standards of their
constitution for all americans he helped
end slavery
wow tear them down no one will ever ask
who he was what he contributed what what
what were his ideas why do we why do we
cherish him why do we look up to him
the first thing he did was when he
became getting free was
to get educated he walked all the way to
the first college that would would teach
him
and he learned dude and he showed and he
was
that's amazing it's like his path is an
incredible story
we'll get to it but it's like that one
dude in the uncle tom film do you know
what i'm talking about
they talk about this in the uncle tom
film yeah what's what's that guy's name
who was like
he's like i went to uh my boss and was
like why aren't i getting a raise and
it's like well the other guy had
had a masters yeah he's like so you know
what i did
i got me a master's and then i came back
i was like i got a master's now
sure enough you got a promotion in a
race yep exactly i i love that story of
like
but that so anyway we'll talk about it
yeah we'll come back to this
but that's why they tear down statues
that's it because when you learn
like people don't realize this dude so
many philosophies
did not exist at one point and many more
will will emerge in the future we don't
know
but before the american revolution
government was
by divine providence it was like the
king is the king
because the the lord mandated as such
right and that and
and you had no choice yeah that's it
that's it and then all of a sudden
it was uh uh it's a literal liberalism
real liberal
liberalism the right of the of the
governed uh the consent of the governed
mm-hmm to uh
started to emerge and then also these
founding fathers were like
nah hold up you know we we can we can do
our own thing we don't need you
yeah and that was like a revolution it
was an ideological revolution yeah
that's why the american evolution is so
important that's why they have to change
history
what are they saying now america was
created 1619.
they want that revelation to be
destroyed
why did they tear down frederick
douglass assuming it was the far left
which i believe it was
it's because he was the person who said
he he one-upped everything he
watered the the the tree of liberty yeah
that's true this idea emerged among
these white slave owners and they did
not fully grasp it
although i i you know people mentioned
the first draft of the declaration
would abolish slavery yep but southern
states were like nah and they needed the
military support
i'm not saying it was the right thing it
was just they created this document
where they had these beliefs in it
but it wasn't fully enforced then you
ended up with people in the future
people like frederick douglass
who watered that tree and that tree
flourished making one of the best
countries if not the best country
on the planet so they got to tear them
down they got to burn the books they got
to ban the books they got to ban the
movies i got to ban the art because they
don't want you to know
because these ideas are inventions
these ideas are you know they they
the the idea of of the consent of the
governed you know innocent until proven
guilty these are created
these are these are ideas that come
together from people who stood on the
shoulders of giants the people who came
before them yep
they got to tear those giants down and
everything everything everything on top
falls down with it
that's that's that's what scares me
about all of this stuff so anyway look
when it comes to
the stuff about the guy in the plane
with you know
black jesus and all that stuff that's
the scary part the fanaticism
yep that's the part where they're just
like
they're they're reading the stuff online
and they're going insane
and they think everyone's a nazi they
think they're living in the star trek
the star wars empire
and everyone's a storm trooper yep they
go to
men let's let's talk about what's going
on in portland
so in uh in portland we're now on day
like 44 or 45 of these riots
okay these people are trying to burn
down the federal courthouse
they uh apparently andy noe tweeted one
guy and a hammer
and he was like bashing through the
window and when the marshals came out he
whacked one of the marshals in the head
with a hammer
and so they subdued him or whatever so
now
now that we have ongoing riots
for over a month not a peep
where's the news where's the big
breaking story where's the you know
federal courthouse being besieged
no nowhere i don't see it anymore i was
talking to a friend earlier
and they told me you know well
i i mentioned someone got fired from
their job for posting a video where they
said they didn't support the writing and
looting and the response i got from my
friend was yeah but the writing looting
has been gone like over for a long time
and i said no no it isn't they declared
a state of emergency in utah like
this week yeah like it was like it was
it was literally last monday i think
no last monday was georgia friday was
was was utah right
and portland's still going on the
media's not talking about it
so you know what they say now they got
the feds deployed
the u.s marshals at a federal courthouse
yep
tom wyden a senator said that trump was
using an occupying army against
peaceful protesters that's ridiculous
peaceful when they're attacking them
with hammers attacking a federal
courthouse yeah
it's federal jurisdiction right this is
exactly what trump supporters said was
gonna happen yeah remember
yeah as soon as trump sent in
federal forces or the military anything
they would claim he was a dictator
that's
this is what i was saying exactly yeah
that's right you get
you you got to give me the credit tim
what was that it was a larger
say it this is this is not fair
i was saying it that's what i've been
talking about sure but there's a
trap they wanted him to do this as soon
as he did it they're going to be like ha
we got you
authoritarian but but you know what's
funny about it
what they did but it's the weakest
iteration of whatever that was supposed
to be
so it reminds me of spongebob and
patrick and like the city's burning and
spongebob's like we did it patrick we
saved the city do you know that meme
so it's an episode of spongebob
squarepants okay the whole city's burnt
to the ground
but spongebob's like we saved it so it's
like
they've they've let these riots go on
for over a month yep
and trump doesn't doesn't move and then
finally after like a month and a half
you had one of the marshals fired a less
lethal munition
it hit some guy in the head and then
they were like now's our chance and they
come out
standing amid the rubble of their
destroyed city trump is an occupy
trump's in an occupying army and there's
fires everywhere and there's like people
beating each other it's like
you know you don't look too good
standing atop this pile of rubble
complaining about trump doing it right i
want to point
fingers yeah got a few pointing back at
yourself
everything is trump's fault everything
leads back to trump
you know what here's the [ __ ] getting
sick of it here's the funny thing though
when i when i
saw the article from willowman weekly
the headline said
uh it was like governor and senators in
or
in oregon condemned trump's use of quote
occupying army
on protesters okay what i thought it
meant
was that trump called them the occupying
army
because they put occupying army in
quotes right i thought they were saying
use of the phrase
against them like trump came out and
said for a month you know this occupying
army's been attacking
right and then i realized i was like
wait wait they're calling the federal
officers in a federal courthouse an
occupying army
right what are you talking about it's a
federal building
right that made no sense that's why i
interpreted it different i thought trump
was calling
the antifa who was attacking and
besieging the courthouse
an occupying army and now you got
minneapolis asking for
federal federal help you know they're
they're they're besieging the the
president please help us now
look at look at this like look how are
you not helping us with this now fire
what happened
now you want now you want his help they
want 15 make up your mind
eight million dollars something it's not
the biggest the total damage is 500
but trump was like nope nope
nope yeah so this is this is this is
that was brutal man
they the tim waltz asked trump to
declare
minnesota disaster zone and he was like
nope
yeah you did this to yourself you know
what i think man i feel bad for the
local businesses
absolutely i feel bad for the innocent
civilians for the people that live there
for sure
only so far you know why because they
voted for these people
that's a good point you want to vote for
a city council that's going to abolish
your police department then don't come
crawling to me asking for money when
people go around burning your buildings
down
and don't call the police this is the
problem you're in trouble
the problem is i'm sure there's a lot of
good people that need help i get it
but if you live in a community that has
an ideology
then maybe you can't live there anymore
i i don't know man listen
if if the feds just keep bailing out
this bad leadership
for all their mistakes it's only going
to get worse you can't
just we can't just keep putting duct
tape on this stuff exactly
new york has been asking for money since
before covid
because they're facing a massive like
7.4 billion
budget shortfall then covet hits and
it's like there's no taxes anymore
because no one's buying anything no
one's getting paid
and so they're like uh oh the trains are
gonna collapse what do we do well we'll
cut the
police budget by one billion dollars how
convenient sure
how convenient and then bill de blasio
got mad because trump was like i'm not
giving you money
well and and you know the whole uh
someone actually banned me today on
facebook they
they were they posted a meme about the
statistics
of opening schools this is this new
battle a new battlefield
opening schools such as not opening
schools and
someone was posting they had this meme
that had all this nice math
and you know it was like oh it's got a
one percent death rate and i i said
you realize over 40 percent or 46
or 47 maybe i don't know the exact i
think it's like 46 percent of all
deaths came from new york from nursing
homes
from cuomo putting in sick patients into
these places and murphy was worse
and actually had a higher higher
percentage in new jersey and new jersey
so i didn't even know this
worse so i just said that and i was like
you know so so this
these numbers don't make sense period
that's it i i didn't like
attack him for it i was just hey that
math is wrong and
he swore at me said do you want to get
uh you want to get bounced
and then he called me some words and
then and then i guess bounced me
off his page wow no loss to me because
you're spreading
false information and i can't stand that
anymore you know what ben shapiro i i
think it was ben shapiro made a really
really good point that i just i loved it
what so he's like um i'll paraphrase it
it was it was a tweet so i want to try
and make it you know the full context
you've got all these different uh states
that are seeing spikes and cases
yeah but they're mostly asymptomatic it
seems and the death
numbers the death numbers keep going
down so i've seen it gone down and down
i've seen a lot of people say yeah but
that's because there's a delay between
confirmed case and when they die which
means in two weeks the death rate's
going to skyrocket
two weeks on it has not skyrocketed yeah
the increase
following labor day and the black lives
matter protest we have not seen an
increase in deaths nope
in fact there's now murmuring i think it
i think it came from ron paul i'm not
entirely sure how to fact-check me on
this one saying the death the
the death numbers globally don't even
qualify for a pandemic anymore it's
below those levels
ben shapiro made a really good point he
said
the reason that new york city is doing
so well right now
is because cuomo de blasio let the virus
run roughshod over the city
killing ever you know killing everybody
now they basically have hurt immunity
right
so why is that why are they all they're
all cheering like yay the numbers are
down it's patrick and
and spongebob going we saved the city
and there's fires everywhere
yep they the people who would get sick
and die the vulnerable people died the
vulnerable people died
many people got sick now there's like
herd immunity and now we're seeing lower
infection rates and lower death rates
because the vulnerable people are
already dead oh
i hate talking about virus me too
me too i'm sick of it it's it but the
numbers don't make sense they don't add
up
we've already always been a little on
the
is this really going on no i mean i i
think it i i
take it seriously but at a certain point
when you've when you you realize we've
lost
and i don't blame trump for it i was
talking to a friend of mine who said
that uh in their state their guidelines
are all backwards broken confusing
contradictory make no sense
like you can't you can't wear a mask
doing this you have to wear a mask doing
this
you can you can you know touch people
for certain jobs and not this one
the cops don't have to wear a mask but
you do how does any of this make sense
or the whole hydro
chloroquine oh man i'll get me started
well i mean i mean but look but
we're talking about it whatever it's
like they
they've the doctors have now said yes
this is a
an incredible drug that's cheap and it
helps people survive this
pandemic we've had another report that
basically said it increases survival
likelihood
and it doesn't necessarily negate all
the other ones but let me tell you the
problem man
fauci comes out and he goes he was
laughing about his interviews like don't
buy masks the surgeon general was like
stop buying masks and and
the reasoning was apparently we were
worried people would buy the masks the
doctors needed
sure but they could have come out and
said
if you are at home you need a cloth mask
to prevent you from spreading to other
people what is it like
it sounds like a fire truck oh a word
street sweeper fire truck no that's
that's an alarm that's not a street
sweeper
but it's getting louder oh boy if the
house burns down no worries get to see
it well it's not our house burning
though no no no no we're good maybe
apocalypse is happening but
it's about time it's the waiting on
cancer we started we start
we are really pushing the boundaries on
on what we talk about though what do you
mean like getting banned
just i mean that's the fire truck though
you know that that sound
it is a fire truck there's a i don't
know if you can actually hear it on the
podcast
maybe it's pretty loud though it's
getting louder it's really annoying
they're coming for us here wait to put
the fire out i'll spin the ufo all right
while he's spinning the ufo i'll just
point this out and everybody's realized
at this point
fauci deserves nothing but criticism
they they've sidelined him for a reason
and we're seeing these news stories
where they're like focused being
sidelined yeah well the dude was wrong
everything you know you know what fouchy
was doing right he'd be like
two days after a news story would come
out he'd go yeah let's
uh not wear masks then two days then the
one story saying better wear a mask two
days later he goes
better wear masks right i was like wait
a minute foggy just comes out two days
after the news cycle and just agrees
with the media he doesn't know what he's
talking about does he
right i've seen i've seen too many
videos of different doctors
sitting in their doctor's office talking
about kovid going
this is ridiculous what we're what we're
going through one thing that needs to be
said
what's up if you need to know what to do
you ask your doctor
ignore everybody else ignore me ignore
adam ignore trump ignore alex jones
ignore foggy
ask your doctor what's right for you
mm-hmm that's the safest thing you can
do
absolutely and if the guidelines are
good and correct and everything your
doctor is going to know what's up
absolutely everybody else is just trying
to play games you know like like
fauci's got his position he's got to
maintain how come fiji never came out
and condemned the protests the riots
because that wasn't his job well he can
talk about people needing to wear masks
he talks about the anti-science and the
asking anti-masking and stuff like that
well why don't he come out and say we
shouldn't have thousands of people
crammed into tight spaces
well he did he did start talk actually
it's funny
that was the last time i remember
hearing from him
he said you know there's a chance that
like you know
the the all these protests might not be
a good thing we might see an uptick in
uh
in cases yeah that was the last time
that was the last time i heard from
fauci
interesting thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show tune in to this
channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on itunes and spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you